whoopi unfortunately tested positive
over the break that's joy behar on the
view revealing why her co-host whoopi
goldberg is not on the first show of the
new year because of the ghost star's
positive diagnosis the ladies return to
taping the show virtually from their
homes as you can see we're back in boxes
and doing the show remotely hopefully
for just a week i'm praying that it's
just a week but you never know because
this alma crime thing is
all over the place as for how whoopi's
doing she'll be back probably next week
um
but since she's vast and boosted her
symptoms have been very very mild but
we're you know being super cautious here
at the view but the cis-drag star isn't
the only one who battled the virus
during the holiday break i too tested
positive
for covid right before christmas and so
i was isolated
alone i facetimed with my family
you know for christmas sonny holston
shared why her battle with kovid was a
particularly trying time for her family
my father-in-law passed away on december
28th and my mother-in-law passed away
uh january 1st and their birthdays were
christmas eve and christmas day and so
it was extremely difficult for my
husband this news comes after the
daytime talk show returned to their
studio last september after nearly two
years of filming virtually and at the
time et spoke with the panelists about
what it was like to be back in front of
a live audience it's all right
you know
i don't think any of us actually wanted
to leave home where we are you know in
our midst but i think
for uh being gone for almost
two years uh we we did a what we know
how to do
but that same month a covet fiasco
happened live on air i need uh the two
of you to step off for a second okay
sonny and anna both apparently tested
positive for covid no matter how hard we
try uh these things happen yup that's
sunny and guest host anna navarro
abruptly being asked to leave their
seats after what they thought were
positive covet 19 tests but fast forward
to the next show and it was revealed
that the two ladies didn't have covet
after all i was flabbergasted and
frankly my first thought was oh my god
it was really uncomfortable for my
results to be
released publicly before
i even knew what was going on all that
aside the ladies of the view are happy
to be well into their 25th season when
et visited the set in september to
celebrate the milestone the four hosts
reflected on the major accomplishment i
like the audience i like the camaraderie
i like the fun of it which is what this
is about now and this is why the view is
popular for this exact reason
listen we're doing we're doing what
we're supposed to be doing this is our
this is our gig and this is
our gift from the world because not
everybody gets to have an opinion not
everybody gets to say this is what i
think and here's why and let's talk
about this this is a really great job
it's a really great job and i'm going to
speak for us but i think real luck is
hell